let's get some practice rewriting
definite integrals as the limit of a
Riemann sum so let's say I wanted to
take the definite integral from PI to 2
pi of cosine of X DX and what I want to
do is I want to write it as the limit as
n approaches infinity of a Riemann sum
so we're going to take the form of the
limit as n approaches infinity and we
can have our Sigma notation right over
here and I would say from let's say I is
equal to 1 all the way to n let's scroll
down a little bit so it doesn't get all
scrunched up at the top of it so let me
draw what's actually going on so that we
can get a better sense of what to write
here within the Sigma notation so large
so if this is pi right over here this
would be 3 PI over 2 and this would be 2
pi all right over here 2 pi now what is
the graph of cosine of X do well at PI
cosine of PI is negative 1 well so
that's negative 1 there and cosine of 2
pi is 1 and so the graph is going to do
something like this and I'm just as
obviously just a hand-drawn version of
it but you have seen cosine functions
before this is just part of it and so
this definite integral represents the
area from PI to 2 pi between the curve
and the x-axis and you might already
know that this area is going to be or
this depth this part of the definite
integral would be negative and this
would be positive and will cancel out
and this would all actually end up being
0 in this case but this exercise for
this video is to rewrite this in re as
the limit as n approaches infinity of a
Riemann sum so there's a Riemann sum
what we want to do is think about
breaking this up into a bunch of
rectangles so let's say Aurel I should
say and rectangles so that's our first
one right over there
then this might be our second one let's
do right Riemann sum where the right
boundary of our rectangle what the value
of the function is at that point that's
what defines the height so that's our
second one all the way until this one
right over here is going to be our nth
one so this is one let me write it this
way this is I is equal to 1 this is I is
equal to two all the way until we get to
I is equal to n and then if we take the
limit as n approaches infinity the sum
of the areas of these rectangles are
going to get better and better and
better and so let's first think about it
what is the width of each of these
rectangles going to be well I am taking
this interval from PI to 2 pi and I'm
going to divide it into n equal
intervals so the width of each of these
the width of each of these is going to
be 2 pi minus pi so I'm just taking the
difference between my bounds of
integration and I am dividing by n which
is equal to PI over n so that's the
width of each of these that's PI over N
this is PI over N this is PI over N and
what's the height of each of these
rectangles remember this is a right
Riemann sum so it's going to be the
right end of our bow of our rectangle is
going to define the height so this right
over here what would this height be well
this height this value I should say this
is going to be equal to F of what well
this was PI and this is going to be PI
plus this the length of our interval
right over here the base of the
rectangle so we started at PI so it's
going to be PI plus this one's going to
be PI over n I could say times 1 that's
this height right over here what's this
one going to be right over here
well this one is going to be F of Pi our
first start plus PI over n times what
we're going to add PI over n 2 times pi
over n times 2 so the general form of
the right boundary is
going to be so for example this height
right over here this is going to be f of
we started at PI plus we're doing the
right Riemann sum so we're going to add
PI over N n times by this point PI over
N times n or if we wanted to say
generally if we're talking about the I
to rectangle remember going to sum them
all up what's their height well the
height is going to be in this case it's
going to be cosine of pi plus if we're
with the height or rectangle we are
going to add PI over n I times pi over n
times I and then that's the height of
each of our rectangles and then what's
the width
well we already figure that out times pi
over N and if you want to be careful and
make sure that this Sigma notation
applies to the whole thing there you
have it we have just reexpress to this
definite integral as the limit of a
right Riemann sum